froh dass ihr hier seid und euch bei
euren eltern zu hause das ist gerade das
querende letzten zeit auf youtube
unterwegs war wird mit aller
wahrscheinlichkeit auf eine serie
gestoßen sein die einen etwas seltsamen
namen trägt die rede ist von der serie
kraft klassenfahrt ich bin tatsächlich
auch beschlossen in dem ich heute im
video youtube durch gebraucht denn was
ich so eigentlich jeden tag mache dann
hab ich diesen namen am rande gesehen
moment mal das heißt doch kraft schule
und da habe ich mich sogar zwei er hat
rtl2 jetzt einfach noch eine sendung
gemacht die auch gast im namen hat jetzt
statt krass schule und auch kraß
klassenfahrt dazu aber ich lag falsch
denn diese serie wird von deutschen
youtube selbst produziert besteht auch
in der beschreibung des kanals versteht
krassen fall eine produktion von jonas
ems und jonas wuttke jonas ems kennen
wir früher jugend ev und das wird es
auch ein deutscher youtuber und ich muss
sagen props 1 jonas union hastig findet
immer geil wenn deutsche youtuber eigene
projekte auf die beine stellen und das
sogar noch selbst machen und ist
natürlich noch krasser vor zwei wochen
dass erst das erste video auf dem kanal
und angekommen und der kanal
kreisklassen vater jetzt schon 132
tausend abonnenten also schaut euch
beide und wir schauen jetzt mal was es
mit dieser serie auf sich hat bevor wir
damit anfangen leute noch kurz meine
lieblings kommentare unter meinem
letzten video unter der action auf
nadine the brain da hat ein account mit
chinesischen schriftzeichen als namen
kommentiert martin weiß dinge über das
universum die keiner von uns jemals
verstehen wird ist die wahrheit habe ich
ziemlich gefeiert und wenn er zum
nächsten und schaut haben wollt dann
kommentiert einfach diesem video mit
lustigem eure meinung was interessant
oder konfekt und nicht mal rein
wir sehen die ersten szenen hier schon
mal eine schulklasse auf klassenfahrt
was im abteil im namen der sendung liebe
schauten verrät uns endlich geht die 12b
eines berliner gymnasiums auf
klassenfahrt doch lehrerin frau
ostermann ist mit dieser chaos klasse
völlig überfordert und was ist stanleys
geheimer plan ist endlich fahren nicht
nach berlin ist das jetzt hier frau
ostermann also die lehrerin der klasse
weil nicht halt genauso alt ihre schüler
hat an der uhr gedreht
[Musik]
ja ja ich weiß nicht wie das heutzutage
abläuft aber ich glaube die
klassenfahrten hat sich noch in der
schule war die liefen bisschen anders ab
also ich muss sagen wer hat an der uhr
gedreht ist natürlich auch schon ein
harter banker der auf jeden fall rein
shepard und in dem ein oder anderen klub
mal gespielt wird
wer hat an der uhr gedreht ich schon zu
spät
[Musik]
hier sind es ein paar von den leuten die
hier in der serie mitspielen also die
bekanntesten sind wahrscheinlich jonas
und seine freundin denise aber sind ein
paar kleiner youtuber dabei und ich muss
sagen ich finde die idee wirklich cool
dass es auf youtube auch reality
scripted reality sendung von youtube
gibt weil ihr könnt es bestimmt auch man
fragt sich ja gerne mal so ein bisschen
ab wenn in den youtube trends wieder nur
türkische serien sind britta sofas 130
türkische serien ist noch ein bisschen
fußball dazwischen
[Musik]
okay das war wirklich frau ostermann
also frau ostermann hat sich wirklich
mitgehalten muss ich sagen die ist echt
also guck mal das ist die lehre hier
das ist die lehrerin und das sind zwei
schülerinnen also sie ein bisschen älter
sind sie schon aus aber er so drei jahre
[Musik]
viel wichtiger ist dass hier die lehrer
mit gutem vorbild voran geht und schon
mal den alkohol parat hat
so flossen ab also wie gesagt ich gebe
dieser serie auf jeden fall so einen
kleinen vertrauensvorschuss gegenüber
den rtl2 sachen aber reicht von youtube
selbst gemacht ist und weil zumindest
der titel schon mal nicht dies ein
einbeiniger stiefvater züchtet elefanten
im keller aber der einstieg ist aber
lustig so klar wir müssen so eine
stimmung aufbauen aber es springt so aus
dem bus raus klassenfahrt
also ich kann da wieder raus meine
eigene erfahrung sprechen aber wenn die
klassenfahrt gegangen bin und aus dem
bus raus durfte endlich dann war ich
eher so ich will euch alle nie wieder
sehen
außerdem auch ein wichtiger punkt den
man hier eventuell noch einbauen kann
wenn eine zwölfte klasse auf
klassenfahrt fährt dann würde ich mal
sagen fallen die schüler er aus dem bus
heraus wenn sie ankommen also ich kann
es ja jetzt wo ich erwachsen bin und aus
der schule raus sagen bei uns ging es
schon in der zehnten anders zur sache im
bus wirklich das war nicht mal schön
angekommen sind was nicht heißt dass man
zu machen sollte leute kein wunder frau
ostermann hat natürlich überhaupt keine
autorität vor ihrer klasse sich so bitte
bitte bitte mir zu kein arsch und das
jetzt irgendein ermittlungen und sorgt
kanal und pokémon go und andere bauten
grill auf vielleicht sind drei jahre
altersunterschied zwischen lehrern und
schülern einfach doch zu wenig ich lass
mal das ist auch waren fing tier
wir sind ja gerade auf dem 3d drehen
krass klassenfahrt deswegen haben wir
auch den bus gemietet deswegen habe ich
auch angeworben als darsteller
wir drehen gerade sendung also mir
scheißegal für mich nicht
hast du bitte aufhören
nein sorry ich wollte was aber da geht
es nämlich losada okay hier sehen wir
dann doch den klassischen schüler einer
zwölften klasse sich aus der
wasserflasche wodka sprite könnten
ich wollte was aufweist wir das nass
wird das ist meine sachen drin
die ganze woche warum sind wir uns halo
habe ich doch schon gesagt das passt
nicht zuständig
so werden sage ich das nicht gerade
ich will mich jetzt mal nicht was das
mal hast du gerade den weg gestellt
in armut unglaublich lahm gerade meine
herrn oben ja da ist erkennen wir direkt
stanley ist schon mal so der mobber
dieser schulklasse hat hier seinen
persönlichen sklaven daneben das
wiederum als sehr realistisch weil ich
glaube jeder schulklasse gibt es immer
einen verzeiht mir den ausdruck
arschloch das ist alle alle unterdrücken
muss ganz einfach nicht glauben ich
könnte genau jetzt im helden sein
in moskau bei meinen eltern und wo bin
ich drecksloch weiter chengdu model
scheinbar liegt eine verwechslung vor
irgendjemand hat kylie jenner statt
einer schülerin der zwölften klasse mit
auf die klassenfahrt genommen bestimmt
nicht mehr strom wasser und handy
leitungen internetleitungen
ich glaube da gibt es keinen strom kein
wasser und glaube auch die die menschen
in dieser ecke klar das ist jetzt
brandenburg oder sohn extra der
brandenburger leben höchstwahrscheinlich
auch noch in zelten
da im hintergrund sehen wir eines dieser
zählte ja was ihr mann sind leitung für
den handy empfangen hoffentlich gibts
überhaupt ein w lan kabel um eine solche
leute mir gerade jetzt hier am wlan
kabel gestoßen
immer froh dass ihr hier seid und ich
schlage euren eltern zu hause das ist
klar das ist tatsächlich die situation
die aus dem echten leben kenne ich die
meisten von euch kann das auch oder also
wenn ihr entweder mit eurer freundin
oder einem freund unterwegs seid und alt
anderen der gruppe single sind man sagt
dann immer so ja ok nein wir hängen
nicht nur auf man darum wir machen nicht
nur um mich schön einfach zusammen alle
als zweite spitze gab es ist halt so
kurz zum kotzen
aber sie könnte auch im hilton seien in
moskau
stattdessen kaufte sie zwei deutschen
youtube bei der gegenseitigen
gesichtsreinigung zunge zu ok ich nehme
es zurück mit es gibt keinen strom und
kein fließendes wasser
es gibt wirklich keinen strom und kein
fließendes wasser
okay das ist wirklich realistisch leute
das bin eins zu eins ich bin nicht stolz
drauf ich finde es nicht gut aber ich
bin wirklich ich bin dieses handy opfer
was die realität verpasst weil sie ganze
zeit und seinem schweizer indirekt
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend möchte das werk voll behandelt
werden ich möchte dass ich auf mich hört
wenn ich was sage ich bin ja die
vertretung von herrn villa nicht möchte
und euch den gute klassen fahren haben
und deshalb wäre es schön öfter mal auf
jonas jetzt gerade im publikum während
die lehrerin die ansage macht
ja genau genommen scheiß werden wir
machen einen anderen mitschülern oder
vielleicht schon mal besser zu
integrieren um die ein bisschen besser
kennen zu lernen
ja ich wollte eigentlich in fragen ob
ich also mit ihnen in einem zimmer
ok ok ok wo ihr coming from raffinierte
hier macht so einen aufstrebenden mit
einem buch über was das biologie oder so
rum dabei dann im entscheidenden moment
stärker zu und sagt zu leeren
ich bin so ein schüchterner kann ich
vielleicht in ihrem zimmer schlafen
ich bin so krass ist die zahl jetzt
geklappt hat weil ich dürfen die jungen
mich ja nicht an zimmer und die uns
geschafft wir können so viel zeug hier
machen ja sie können viel zeug da machen
auf jeden fall
probierst du musst losbude ich muss noch
mal den namen die reihe bekommen also
jonas ist kenne und die nächste joline
jetzt kriegt joline also denise von dem
motto war der klassische scheinbar von
ständig die folgende nachricht ich freue
mich auf heute nacht es wird hart
auberginen energy wassertropfen energy
während sie neben ihrem freund sitzt ja
ja ich glaube das geht in eine gute
richtung leute vor allem weil sie
einfach binz sind durch zieht also na ja
also heute nach wird es hart wird dann
gehe ich jetzt mal weg
was findet man in dieser folge auf
wollte diese serie ist auf jeden fall
schon mal deutlich abstoßender als das
was wir sonst von den eigentlichen
vertretern dieses genres vor allem rtl 2
kennen und dafür muss man wirklich pops
geben also dann leute ich hab ich eine
beschreibung die folge verlinkt check
die gerne ab hier doch ihm fehlt nur
noch eine reaktion auf wichtige city
frau ich habe das auch anschauen wollt
bis zum nächsten video